[Música]
la fiscalía de Ecuador solicitó el
arresto domiciliario por el expresidente
Lenin Moreno por un caso de corrupción
en el marco del caso sino hidro el ex
mandatario es señalado de recibir
presuntos sobornos por la construcción
de una hidroeléctrica Tenemos reporte
desde quito
Colombia sigue sin controlar por
completo la violencia así lo dio a
conocer la oficina de Naciones Unidas
para los Derechos Humanos al pedir a las
autoridades de ese país que aceleren el
desmantelamiento de grupos armados y
eviten más asesinatos de líderes
sociales que aumentaron en 2022
la revista Time la más leída de Estados
Unidos cumple 100 años de historia Un
siglo de nuestro tiempo que queda
reflejado en sus icónicas portadas en
esta edición repasaremos los momentos
más destacados de esta publicación
y es momento de revisar las noticias del
continente americano para mí es un
placer acompañarlos Mi nombre es Juan
Pablo lucumí comenzamos esta Informativo
en Ecuador porque la fiscalía del país
pidió el arresto domiciliario al
expresidente Lenin Moreno por supuesto
corrupción la decisión da en el marco
del caso sino hidro que gira en torno a
presuntos sobornos recibidos por la
construcción de una central
hidroeléctrica nuestro corresponsal en
Quito Gustavo Ortega nos reportó
previamente al respecto
la fiscal general del estado ha
presentado los cargos enmarcados en la
investigación del caso sino hidro y ha
formulado prisión preventiva para 37
involucrados 14 de ellos superan los 65
años por el cual estos ha solicitado
arresto domiciliario específicamente ha
señalado al ex vicepresidente de Ecuador
Lenin Moreno por haber recibido
beneficios económicos se habla según la
fiscal general del estado de un caso de
corrupción de 76 millones de dólares De
igual forma señaló que tan solo el
entorno familiar del ex vicepresidente
de Ecuador lenín Moreno había recibido
beneficios económicos por
660.000 dólares ella hacía un detalle de
cuáles habrían sido los beneficios
económicos que recibe el entorno
presidencial el entorno del ex segundo
al mando de Ecuador y específicamente
detalló Leo textualmente la cita de la
fiscal general el vicepresidente tanto
como su esposa habrían recibido
veinte mil dólares esto en beneficios de
un apartamento y muebles para este
apartamento de alicante De igual forma
también señala a su hija de haber
recibido 50 mil dólares a dos de sus
hermanos por Diez mil y trescientos
cincuenta mil dólares y De igual forma a
dos cuñadas y a la suegra quien señala
por beneficios de Diez mil quince mil y
cinco mil dólares esto es una
investigación por parte que realiza la
fiscal general del estado hace cinco
años involucrado en el caso sino hidro y
la oficina de Naciones Unidas para los
Derechos Humanos hizo un llamado a
acelerar el desmantelamiento de los
grupos armados en Colombia el organismo
presentó un informe en el que muestra
que diferentes tipos de violencia como
la masacre o los asesinatos de líderes
sociales aumentaron en 2022
la violencia en Colombia no cesa la
oficina de Naciones Unidas para los
Derechos Humanos reiteró su llamado para
acelerar el desmantelamiento de los
grupos armados del país el pedido se
enmarca en un informe que presenta
cifras desalentadoras sobre la violencia
en Colombia el año pasado hemos visto el
efecto de la violencia de los grupos
armados en los territorios y por eso
llamamos tanto a la política de
desmantelamiento porque son los grupos
armados no estatales y las
organizaciones criminales quienes están
generando tanta violencia en los
territorios las masacres en el país
aumentaron a 92 en 2022 En comparación
con la 78 2021 también en el año
anterior 116 líderes comunitarios y
activistas sociales fueron asesinados
con respecto a los 100 que murieron en
2021 hemos visto que en el 2022 siguen
habiendo altos niveles de masacres
homicidios de personas defensoras además
de la violencia cotidiana que sufren las
poblaciones y la del tejido social en
los territorios
2022 fue un año de transición en
Colombia la presidencia pasó de manos de
Iván Duque de tendencia derechista a las
de Gustavo Petro el primer mandatario de
izquierda del país un cambio en el poder
que también se reflejó en la concepción
de cómo contrarrestar la violencia Petro
ha impulsado como base de su programa
político la paz Total que busca abarcar
a los diferentes grupos armados del país
el gobierno ha reiniciado conversaciones
con el ejército de liberación nacional y
ha acordado el cese al fuego con bandas
criminales y dos facciones de las
disidencias de las FARC unos pasos que
siguen estando lejos de su meta de
ponerle Punto Final al conflicto de más
de 60 años en el que al menos 450.000
personas han perdido la vida
en un equipo de expertos de Derechos
Humanos designado por Naciones Unidas
concluyó que el gobierno de Nicaragua ha
cometido violaciones sistemáticas que
constituyen crímenes de lesa humanidad
el equipo pidió sanciones
internacionales contra el gobierno
liderado por el presidente Daniel Ortega
y su esposa la vicepresidenta Rosario
Murillo a quienes acusan de abusos como
violaciones sexuales ejecuciones
extrajudiciales entre otros crímenes más
en el informe de Natalia plazas
un estado utilizado como arma de
represión contra su población así
resumido Naciones Unidas la forma en que
el gobierno nicaragüense ha tratado a
sus ciudadanos desde que en 2018 una
protesta ciudadana estalló en contra del
presidente Daniel Ortega y su esposa a
la vicepresidenta Rosario Murillo se
trata de un informe realizado por una
misión en el país que resalta una
multiplicidad de crímenes de lesa
humanidad cometidos de manera
sistemática
estas violaciones y abusos se perpetran
de manera generalizada por motivos
políticos y constituyen crímenes de lesa
humanidad de asesinato encarcelamiento
tortura incluida la violencia sexual
deportación y persecución por motivos
políticos también identificó ejecuciones
extrajudiciales realizadas por agentes
policiales y miembros de grupos
paramilitares durante las protestas de
2018 el informe concluyó que el
presidente Ortega y la vicepresidenta
Murillo han puesto en funcionamiento
estos crímenes y que muchos de estos
siguen ocurriendo
sino realizando a través de reformas
constitucionales legales y de una u otra
manera frente a procesos en donde se
ejecutaron de manera coordinada con
diferentes estructuras del Estado
acciones que fueron sistemáticas y
generalizadas dentro de un ataque que
implica violaciones y crímenes de toda
índole en los últimos años son miles los
opositores que han tenido que abandonar
el país en medio de la represión al
menos 3.144 organizaciones de la
sociedad civil han sido clausuradas y
casi todos los medios independientes
operan en el exterior pero la situación
empeora con el tiempo en el último mes
las autoridades despojaron de su
nacionalidad a más de 200 personas
acusadas de ser traidores a la patria
[Música]
y la revista Time cumple este viernes
100 años desde su primera publicación el
icónico magazine del marco rojo ha
lanzado más de 5000 entregas y alcanzó
más de un millón de suscriptores el
medio planea una serie de eventos en el
mundo Durante este 2023 a modo de
celebración repasamos el recorrido
histórico de la revista en este informe
de Ramiro cué Barberena
la reconocida revista estadounidense
Time cumple 100 años este viernes desde
su inicio el 3 de marzo de 1923 se ha
convertido en el medio más leído en
Estados Unidos publicando más de 5.000
ediciones y sumando más de un millón de
suscriptores
todos estamos inundados de millones y
millones de imágenes que nos lanzan cada
día
siempre es gratamente sorprendente ver
como una portada de Time puede abrirse
paso en ese abarrotado panorama
mediático una portada de Time tiene que
ser Clara gráfica y a veces provocativa
pero siempre intenta arrojar un tema de
importancia dentro de ese marco rojo
intento pensar en ella como un póster
periodístico de nuestro tiempo
la figura de su primera portada fue el
legislador republicano Joseph Canon
quien anunciaba su retiro como
presidente de la cámara de
representantes a lo largo de su siglo de
existencia la revista ha sacado
ejemplares que trascendieron como la de
abril de 1966 cuando preguntaban Dios
está muerto o hay polémico titular eres
lo suficientemente madre
también se han ocupado de temas
históricos como el ataque de las Torres
Gemelas en 2001 y han graficado la
realidad con El retrato de Aisha una
mujer afgana a quienes los talibanes le
cortaron la nariz y las orejas en 2010 o
ironizando sobre la postura migratoria
estadounidense durante el gobierno de
Donald Trump con el título Bienvenidos a
Estados Unidos la guerra en Ucrania no
pasó desapercibida y le otorgaron la
distinción de personaje del año al
presidente boladímir selenski y el
espíritu ucraniano
Time planea celebrar su centenario con
eventos en todo el mundo a lo largo de
2023 junto a líderes mundiales y figuras
de distintos ámbitos
y así llegamos al final de esta
informativo pero pueden tener más en
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]